what about your brother he's an artist
he went to art school too and studied
Fine Art and he yeah so he also is in
the creative world does he ever ask for
residuals from the Harry Potter movies
because I I read that is it true that he
was the one who was reading the uh the
books and then he says to you
um you know you just remind me of Ginny
Weasley yeah he was really specific
people like have heard that they were
making them into movies and auditioning
and he was like you need to go for the
role of Ginny Weasley I was like okay
don't even know who that is or like what
this book is but it sounds fun did you
read it before you so yeah before I went
to the first audition I read the first
book
um which Ginny isn't really in that much
at all so I didn't really get a sense of
her she obviously comes through more in
in the second book
um but I
yeah it was very much
you know I looked up to my brother
massively and was very ignore of him so
if he had like an idea I was like yeah
that sounds good
and I'm grateful he had that great
casting ability to
I mean what are the odds though hey
there folks it's Michael Rosenbaum and
boy have I got a huge announcement for
you this has been a long time comment
and it's finally here
I'm doing a live podcast my podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum is
going live yeah for the first time ever
on Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
not going to be alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember he's been on the podcast he's a
friend of the show the one the only
Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up on
life and mental health and we're gonna
have a really good time with all of you
I think you know that we're going to
make it a lot of fun we're planning a q
a maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs insights and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there
could you imagine your brother just goes
you should be this character go find a
way to audition for one of the biggest
movies ever that I guess you knew the
books were huge so it was potential that
the movies were going to be gay but like
I I mean where do you even go is it
something that I mean where did you grow
up in London so they just had casting in
London no it wasn't like an open casting
so my mom I think like I think they came
home from work and we were like we we
want to we want to find how we get an
audition in Harry Potter my parents are
like
I have no idea we don't know anything in
anyone in the entertainment industry so
my mum being clever and like ready for
the challenge of like figuring it out
called the Publishers in the UK which is
Bloomsbury Publishers they gave her the
casting casting director's number uh or
contact or whatever she contacted them
and they said okay sure if you want to
send in some pictures of Bonnie and if
she could write a couple sentences of
who why she wants to play Ginny and what
did you say I my mum still has the
little the sentences somewhere I wrote
down I'll have to find it I think she's
confident and smart and I think
um I'd be a great Jenny
um you were nine yes I was nine and then
I went yeah for it in total just two
auditions one just with the casting
director and then the second with David
Hayman abduser and Christopher Columbus
the director how how big was the uh how
how many lines did you have for this
audition so I didn't even so because
Ginny had no lines in the first film the
actual line I had in the film which was
one line was given to me on the day
Chris Columbus was like at the train
station or whatever which is my good
luck to Harry
um so I actually read Hermione lines
because they didn't have any other scene
for me to read so they were like okay
you're gonna have to just read this
character
so I read yeah and were you nervous
yeah I was nervous I think I he done
some plays in school but nothing is
really big I honestly did not think I
was gonna get it I was just like this
could be fun let's go see what on
audition's like you know I wasn't I was
someone who as a kid like loved taking
part in everything but I was never and
still not like I not competitive like I
love like for instance I used to love
sports but I never probably would have
gotten anywhere because I just wasn't
competitive so my brother and I were
just like let's go and just figure like
check this out kind of thing and did not
you know just walked away from the first
audition being like I don't know what
that was you know forgot about it that
was fun moving on and then it was quite
a while after where when I actually we
got like the call back to then come and
meet
um David Heyman and Christopher Columbus
and I was like then I was like way more
nervous than that I was like oh gosh I'm
leaving with the guy who uh found
America
no no it's not that Christopher Columbus
come on not that one
um please there was the other one
um but yeah so I was like pretty nervous